this is a production of cornell
university
thank you so much adrian for this uh
great introduction
um can you guys hear me okay good okay
so um
you know until about a year ago in uh
department of seminars like this
um i usually started the
talk by sort of laying out a big problem
in biology and then
that i have some sort of vision to
address that problem
because that's what you're supposed to
do right you're actually you know
running a research lab you're supposed
to work on a huge problem
um but then a year ago when they told me
that i had a tenure
and from that moment you know when i
first heard the news and the first thing
that actually came to my mind
it was damn from now on
i can't shame this shame you just i
don't have any visions
so well now that i don't want it i just
don't have it
so what i do have though is a passion
for organisms and that's really what's
what has been driving my research
program and in particular i'm very
passionate
about um this group of organisms called
the monkey flowers
and this is a wild flower genus the
cheetah's name is the mimerus
it contains about 150 species mostly
found in
western north america and in the past
in the past 10 years as you can see that
there's a huge diversity
in the genus in terms of flower
pigmentation patterns and floral form
and in the past 10 years
i've been working on this one particular
clay this particular group of monkey
flowers
but before i uh uh before i tell you
that what we have been doing with those
species
i want to take a very brief detour back
to my graduate school days
so like agents that i do my ph.d uh at
university of washington
uh actually on plant taxonomy so the
plant taxonomy is you know what you do
most of the time is actually really fun
is you go out in the mountains and you
just look at the plants and identify
and you know families genus and species
etc
and but of course flowers is a
floral trees are the most important
characteristic of
a plant that you can rely on to classify
those plants
so i've been looking at the flowers for
for ages
and of course and i was well fine but
once in a long while you know once in a
long while
i wouldn't i can't help thinking what
makes
what is beautiful this breathtaking
beauty of those flowers
right like but but again i was a plant
taxonomist i mean i was i was just
thinking about it once in a long while
and i
didn't think i didn't think this is a
problem i should be asking
um you know those that should be planned
development about it just to work on
that
right so i didn't really i didn't really
think about i would ever work on that
until one day um i encountered you know
i'll tell you you know select what you
uh you can't
encounter the monkey flower species so
but if we
actually think about for just a moment
about this problem like what makes that
blood taken beauty
so we're really thinking about three
different things
one is you know what is the most basic
genetic and developmental control of all
of the elaborate
floral features i'm not talking about
you know how do you make a difference
from a flower because that's
already long you know resolved by using
abdominopsis right
but once you have the flower now how do
you elaborate the flower
into so many different colors so many
different shapes
and the second question is okay so how
do you go
from one species to another and how do
they diversify
and then the third question is on the
what kind of
on what kind of so this is the first
second and then and what kind of
ecological circumstance that the species
diversify
like why do they diversify why do they
change your flower morphology and flower
color
in the way they do right so what is the
ecological context that's driving the
evolution of flower diversity
so to address one of the three questions
it's actually really difficult
because you need to have a system that
to be able to do all
the three things and that's really
unusual and
of course that's where the monkey flower
came in again like i never thought i
would work out of the problems
until one day i saw those beautiful
images if there's one particular species
called new mules in the west side
and this is really one of those royal
moments of uh
you know true love in the uh on first
side
um well if you are tweeting please don't
pray like uh please don't
put my word on twitter because my wife
might be on twitter
um so anyway on the left side those are
the wild type
uh that's how the wild type looks like
for this one particular species
and then in the central column and
that's the that's the that's the mutant
those are single gene ems or chemically
induced mutant
okay now if you just do kind of meal
tense
it looks like it's not a big deal right
i mean you basically are
changing a flower you're more or less
actually disrupting
a wild type a beautiful flower into
those ugly shapes right
only if actually you are familiar with a
diversity of flowers
then you would think it very differently
so this is what i saw from those mutants
you know night mutant just looks like
something totally different in another
family
some of you might be familiar with that
flower this is a very
popular horticultural pythagorean right
and this looks like a monocot have like
a three petals
and those these this mutant have this
link to the petal
it's just like a real species right etc
and so on so i have a large collection
of mutants and they
kind of like capture this one single
species you know the different buildings
can capture
a large part of the diversity that
you're actually seeing in natural
species in even distinct related
families
so that actually offers an opportunity
to study
the basic genetic and development of
control for example if you can figure
out
what is the difference between this wild
type and a mutant let me tell you
something about
how you know in the natural world what
distinguish
this this kind of flower with that kind
of flower right
and without those mutants you can't
really do that because those are like
two different totally different families
you can't possibly cross them and to do
traditional genetics
right with mutants though you can do
classic genetics and developmental
biology
so that could potentially tell you how
do things work
i know of course as i said i'm also
interested in how you how does
this morphology and color and
pigmentation pattern let's change it
from species to species
so on on a much finer scale like how
evolution actually happens right
what kind of genetic tinkering is
actually happening in those species
to these you know for example going from
a a deponent to a species like this
to a homophobic species like that and
that requires you
to have a group of closely related
species now with
dramatic morphological evaluation now
you can actually do
real genetics right also developmental
biology to actually look at what is the
real basis what is the molecular basis
of evolution you know over the change
from species to species
now as i also said um one of the species
again is ideal because you can actually
cross and make a really healthy iphones
and as well it's generating efficiencies
that um you know why they sacred
segregate for water florida trades so
you can basically do
classic genetics with it and the third
reason that this system is particularly
appealing to me
is that that's a very rich history
of you know ecological studies have done
under the first
you know particular species i just
talked about and uh
it's very well you know a low natural
history like where do they grow what
kind of hybridity like and what kind of
pollinators do you use
and what kind of you know temperature
and water regimes they
they thrive in the wild et cetera et
cetera so this actually allows a
allows you know later on you can put
those molecular biology the genetics the
development
back to the ecological context so that's
why actually i i i started working on a
species
and of course then uh when i you know
moved to yukon um
you know decided to start thinking about
what i'm going to work on so
as a plan you know deep in my heart i
feel like i'm going to do a plan
taxonomies and i always go back to this
slide
so we just look at those flowers right
there are lots of floral trees actually
the basic genetic and development
control
that people haven't known yet for
example that
this kind of structure is called the
chlora tube like many the individual
petras
they fuse together into a tubular
structure now of course the labidoxis
have
four separate patterns right but
actually more than 80
000 species have you know chlorotubes
like this
another chlorophyll is very important
for you know the lens and white
and curvature are very important for
determining what kind of
pollinators they're going to use and
because the pollinators are different
and they're going to need to
reproductive isolation and speciation
so it's really it's a very important
floral structure that drives
diversification of
plants so i decided while the first
the first to fit the treat we're going
to work on is this is this cooler tube
since people don't know anything about
it
and we might be able to make a little
contribution to that and
because we are actually another main
reason why we why we chose to work on
that as the first sort of the first
treat that we're going to focus on um is
because we have this collection of
mutants so this is the wild type right
and you see there's a beautiful
chlorotube
and we have a bunch of mutants that the
tube is disrupted now of course if you
want to freak out
like how does the tube or the form in
the wild type
you need you know you do you need to
make use of the mutants you need to
figure out what's wrong in the mutant
right
and then you can reconstruct what
happens in the wildlife
so we have a lot of mutants with the
tube formation disrupted that's why we
started with this phenotype
and i'm going to just uh talk about in
sort of a slight detail of
a couple of a couple of those mutants
today um and now i'm going to go through
hopefully i have time in just you know
two or three other projects
very briefly without any details so the
two mute the two meters i'm going to
talk about right now is another two is
called a fleet one fleet tube
with you know the color tube split and
we you know a lot quite several years
ago we did this book separating analysis
when you know where it's getting really
easy to sequence the genomes and you can
identify the cause of genes
of those mutants very rapidly so we do
that very very very smoothly
and it turns out that those two genes
and by the way they're actually
phenotypically indistinguishable so in
the greenhouse when you look at them you
can't really tell them apart they look
essentially the same okay and then you
can also uh make a double build and they
also
it's indistinguishable from each other
so when we clone the gene it turns out
one of them
encodes the alkyl logist seven uh the
arrhythmias ortholog algorithm seven
and the other one is the surprise of
gene cytosine three
now of course when we um first
you know isolate those genes we want to
verify this you know why do we have
actually got the right gene
right because we only want to have one
or two radius for youtubers
for each of those mutants so we want to
do a right q experiment
and then you can just basically put the
full-length coding dna
of whatever gene you think it is into
the mutant background so whether you can
rise kill the phenotype
so in this case for example in fluid one
and we have you know a large proportion
of the uh
transgenic lines that fully rise kill
the phenotype
and some of them actually have a partial
skew which is actually important very
informative
because they actually even rise kill the
the land the wife of the petal
now the mutant actually have a light or
petrus
you see that the the petal white was
actually restored
but the tube is steel not formed yet
right the same thing for the other for
the other gene but in any event
this experiment told us that we must
have got the right gene
now the last question of course you know
like any other plan by allergy problems
when you when you got a new gene well
this is not you're going to do gene
right
you ask the question okay what does this
gene do in robloxis
because we have of course we you know
nobody has studied like you mean with us
before right so you want you want to say
okay what does that do about diaphysis
and it turns out you know
in the beginning it was really just i
was really disappointed because those
two genes are very well characterized in
your laboratories
as well as a few other plant systems and
they actually cause
they include two of the components on
this uh
uh uh biogenesis pathway of a special
type of
small on the implants it's called a
transaction short interference rna world
target army
now this is a simplified version of that
complicated network okay
so those are the two genes the algo7 and
the str3
corresponding to our mutants so since
now we know that we we we're pretty
confident we got a gene right
and now based on this pathway you can
make a lot of predictions right
you can predict in the mutant that this
ponzi on abundance must be reduced right
because those proteins are required
to generate the taxi rnas and
another reason i was really disappointed
in the beginning uh because then you
have to
you have to do something with a small
artist and i was
generally kind of i don't know why it's
just a weird personality i'm a little
bit against
fashionable things and about seven years
ago when i first identified a gene you
know small honey was really hard like a
lot of people are working on smart i
don't wanna i don't want to work on
something that everybody else is working
on
that was really disappointing and uh the
other thing is that we you know we never
had any experience in working with this
morning
so i basically like included um you know
the best people actually know how to
work with small honey so blake myers is
really one of the uh
uh kind of the king of pants more honest
right and
and luisha uh he was actually a poster
in blake's lab and now he's uh
running his own a very successful lab in
china uh so back in he was a studio
poster in his lab and
and and we really did all the small
arnold work uh for us
and uh you know the results was very
clear when we sequenced those
built-ins that this target rna abundance
is basically decreased to almost zero
so that first prediction definitely will
burn out
now the second prediction is now in
labor says
that the tarzan is known to reprice the
exploiting of
two oxygen response factors of three and
four
posted transcriptionally so if the
tarzian
abundance decreased in the mutants then
the r3 and r4
exploitation should be upper regulated
right so this
was our second prediction and that's
easy to test because you can just run a
quantitative pcr
and you do say that they both have 3 and
up 4 are upper regulated
but not very dramatically because this
is actually a long feature of a small
rna regulation
and they often don't really dramatically
change the expression level it's more
like a fine-tuned
sort of uh uh rule so and this is
actually consistent with what was known
in your laptops when you lock out those
housing on a after app for it's only
model really upper regulated
now the third prediction you can make is
okay so now we think
there's a phenotype it's a mutant
phenotype what's the mediah
basically through the upper regulation
of
f3 and r4 right so then if you
artificially
over experience after and r4 in the wild
type
you should be able to recapitulate the
mutant phenotype
so this is our third prediction and we
did exactly that
and of course you have to you know it's
a little bit more complicated because i
have to change the coding dna a little
bit to make sure it's not sensitive to
the small rna otherwise
if you only if you just overexpress the
original coding dna
that the s'more only works due down
regulatory lab so you have to change you
make some mutations in the gene
make sure it's insensitive to the uh
small rna but when we do that
that the d phenotype it was basically
indistinguishable from those mutants
uh i didn't mention that the phenotype
before but they are much lighter than
the wild type and then the flower is now
you know the single
the when you're overexposed it's just
either of three or four
they don't fully recapitulate they they
flip
uh phenotypes but the tubes are
partially split as you can tell right
and also it's a little
lateral and then when we cross the two
transgenic lines together when you
basically overexpress both genes
and then you get a phenotype that is
actually a lot more similar to the to
the mutant it's
still not identical but it's actually a
lot more similar
so by now we kind of know like okay so
those two mutants actually caused by
uh the small on a biogenesis pathway and
then the phenotype was largely but maybe
not completely
uh mediated through the auxin response
factors
right so you might ask and then
so what right this whole pathway is
known from another autobiopsies and so
far we really haven't
discovered anything new yet right i mean
we showed this you know
it's true that i produce an interesting
phenotype but we still don't really know
how does this work in the wild type
right how does the wildcat tubal deform
and so you know for for a long time i've
been like wondering okay what does this
one mean
and i did not even you know we again we
we we figure out the gene
you know in 2013 and then um you know we
did a little transgenic work by like at
the end of 2015
but for a long time i didn't really do
anything with that project and
i didn't even write a grand proposal
because i did not have a model
like how this works in a wild type right
and then i have a uh post stuff we're
actually sort of keeping this project on
and off and uh
crazy being thinking of course you know
a lot more than i do like most of
postdocs do you know
more than i put in like advisors right
so he's been reading a bunch of papers
and then
we found that it's in petunia that is
this gene called a wax like microscanner
would be very interested in that
um as roxy when you mutate that you
actually produce a split phenotype
acryla tube and then also your morning
glories
that is a cannot gene where you're
knocking out you'll also
see those sort of split chlorotubes and
i
actually write those papers before i
just never really put them together i
never thought about them in a way that
my post i did
so when he put us together and he just
said it
he told me like oh you know the rocks
and you know the the kannadigi and
there's a taji on it and the r3r4
these are actually in the same genetic
network that you know labs is
known to be responsible for the
establishment and maintenance
of the leaf a toxic or bacterial
identity or polarity
as well as the natural growth of the of
the liver blade
so when you mutate some of those genes
then the lateral expansion of the leaf
basically comes to a hold it doesn't it
doesn't expand naturally anymore
and then considering that meanwhile you
do it in a time like i have a colleague
a
primary diego in the department who is
actually a really good uh convention
sort of
not an anatomist and plant morphologist
and she another student vandana gurong
and they were doing some icm
with us and you can tell that in the
beginning in the very early development
stages
now the pilot pro module they're
definitely initiated separately
and then you know you know in a
particularly critical stage
that the pilot promoter somehow then
fuses together into this structure
that is more obvious over here and that
basically forms the cholera tube
so now you know when i put two things
together you know my post docs
this funding of the genetic network and
then um pam giving up her students
sgm images i was thinking okay so maybe
the way that it works in in the you know
in the wild type
is that those pipers initiate separately
and then in the early stage the base of
the pineapple module
they have a lot of very rapid natural
expansion just like the different model
right it goes like
laterally and that of course requires
the need for a toxic or box cell genetic
network
without that that the base of the python
promoter won't be able to expand
right so that would explain those
mutants phenotypes
so in a wild type or maybe those you
know the base of the pattern promoter
grows like
towards each other like this and then
when they touch each other
and then they you know it's going to
involve some sort of epidermal
cell uh due differentiation like the
oxygen over the cell when it began and
the
cells actually fuse with each other and
then you get this beautiful tube right
so a lot of time i thought okay i
finally have a working model
and um and just like i what i just
described it to you and i sort of
explained those mutant phenotypes that
people know before but also you know
earlier papers people had a little idea
but didn't really say anything about
how does that supposed to work you know
um
and then i sort of decided this is this
is this is the model i'm gonna go with
right and this is i call it
the lyco model that i just told you
because well one reason because my case
was that i could play
like all day every day like a lot of
time and i've been thinking about legos
and i've been thinking about how cell
grows and touch each other kind of like
like how you
put the lego pieces together right so
this is sort of my central hypothesis
and i was like okay now we're ready to
write a gram proposal because you know
you need to have a central hypothesis
for grant proposal and i remember that
was 2017 that was 2017 i remember very
clearly because that was the day
before the proposal is due and uh elena
creamer from harvard
university came to our school to give a
seminar
and then after the seminar of course uh
this is pam digger again
and then cindy jones is also not a
really good plant morphologist in
my department so the four of us went to
dinner
and we were just i was trying to enjoy
my meal because i had to scramble to do
the last day so i have you know i'm
gonna have to
have a long night to work on that right
so i was just enjoying my meal and then
they were asking me yeah well
what's happening with you what are you
working on right now so i told him this
thing i was working as a proposer and
this is my central hypothesis
and then as soon as i was done and the
three of lame
like simultaneously said no
this is not how plant tissue grows they
don't just like a ligo you know like a
piece together like that
and i was like i was like why not
and then they started telling me like
why not and they said educating me
basically giving me a whole lecture
about how plant tissue actually grows
and of course by the end i was uh i was
feeling very depressed
it's not because i don't like people
telling me i wasn't wrong i mean i like
like actually because this is how you
learn right
but i don't like people telling me my
central hypothesis was wrong the day
before my grand proposal is due
it was too late to change my central
hypothesis right
so after again i went home and i kind of
finished it and i was like well you know
there's not much i can do
to change the proposal i can only just
get as a media and then secretly wishing
you know maybe those reviewers are more
like me you know who are just interested
in gene function but
you know maybe not necessarily familiar
with how plant tissue grows
right but of course it turns out that um
the other reviewers were just like me
they're actually liking my model
and they should give they actually give
us money so
for a completely long model but of
course and then after that after we got
them
money i mean we have to do the right
thing right to do the right experiment
so now i've been actually pounding about
those icm images primed
collected uh yeah i've been pumping that
a little more
and especially when you compare with the
mutants right you want to see what is
the difference
what is the what is the difference
between the mutant and the wild type
during
development right as you can sort of
camera in the very beginning state a
very early stage they're actually very
similar
it's only in a in a stage that about you
know this sort of size
which i'm going to show you in the next
slide in the zoom in version
that you can tell the difference is
happening so in a mutant
you see there's a pattern promoter is
like growing upward
in a wild type it was more like they're
growing sideways
but together together with this region
this zone
called the inter-promotion region or the
inter-promoter
zone in a mutant now this zone just
completely stopped growing so the growth
is completely arrested
it's not really about how the base of
the pilot promoter is actually going
another one
laterally like this and that one was
going like that and they touch each
other
right in the wild type it actually
involves the synchronize the growth
between the base of the particle module
and the inter-promotional region
now again in the mutant this
inter-promoted region growth was
entirely arrested it almost sounds like
when i look at those
images for you know for day after day
and i started imagining
it's almost like in the wild type there
is this molecular signal
it's communicating between this
inter-promotional region
and the base of the particle promoter
and
in the mutant this signal is disrupted
and then of course you won't you know
you won't you won't have synchronized
growth anymore
and that would you know explain the
phenotype
but what kind of molecular signal would
that be right and of course you know we
all know
in plant biology and oxygen is
everything right the hormone oxygen
that triggers that localizes the tissue
growth so i would imagine okay maybe
it's actually oxygen maybe oxygen is
actually you know in the wild type
is triggering or induces synchronizer
growth
between the base of the primordial and
the inter-promoter region
but how do we shield that right and i
one day i was asking my poster
i was telling him how you know what i
think this is really my only
contribution to this whole project
so i told him what i'm what i was
thinking i think i thought you know
that must be something like an oxygen is
it a communicating between it
and but how do we show that i wish you
would have an oxygen response you know
responsibly proton or something and my
poster goes
oh we have one i made one like six
months six months ago
i was like okay okay then what is that
do you see a pattern of auxin response
like what i just imagined
it was like now because i was trying to
actually image this whole robot like for
two months now and i couldn't get it to
work i mean i can
i can imagine the individual pattern um
because those floral bars are a lot
a lot larger than uh diopsides so
especially by the stage they uh um you
know
they form the tube it's already you know
sort of fairly large and about 0.5
millimeter you know
and and to to to do a whole floor of you
on the
floor license for a microscope or you
know confocal microscope is pretty hard
and to his defense so my post i was uh
actually you might
remember i had this sort of a scuba
diver image right i just showed
that was because he was doing fish
behavior ecology so that's what he did
his phd on
fish behavioral ecology so it's
understandable that he's another
what the most you know experienced
expert in in confocal imaging right
so so anyway so he basically said well
you can't really we can't really give it
to this whole photo but i was like okay
that's a little bit disappointing and
then after a few months i have a new
graduate student came in
who was actually a uh who's
undergraduate background was in
bioinformatics
so i never thought she would do anything
you know she would have
she was i i sort of like bluetooth to
work on the genome project
much to japan development but she heard
about this theme from my post like she
wants to give it a try
and within like you know a week she got
us a beautiful image you know this whole
floor about
and look at that that's exactly like
what i was imagining
the inter-promotional region so that the
right signal is the oxygen response okay
and then the the debate the base of the
the parapromotion and the
inter-promotional region is from this
continuous signal
signal of oxygen response and then
there's a gap
between that region and the chief of the
particle motor and when the
particles goes a little bit bigger this
pattern is even more obvious you can
let's see in the primordial region and
the base of the paramour
do you have this continuous pattern
whereas the upper words is actually
you know signal is gone and one day of
course
up to this point this tube is basically
already formed okay afterwards it's just
a zonal growth it's just like you know
upper growth and then later on the
signal was actually more spread into the
the whole pattern margin it's probably
the quality with you know whole
cruel uh growth the better lower growth
as well not just the two
right and if you compare that with the
mutant like community
the whole mutant even the whole of it
have like much
lower signal and also especially in the
really important region that's the
important reason right
it was like no signal at all so that was
really totally
you know consistent with what we were
imagining that in the mutant
signal is basically disrupted and
therefore you don't have to synchronize
the growth
between the you know base of the
perimeter and the inter-promoter region
and therefore you don't form a tube
so this is what sort of kind of makes
sense starting making sense and then you
know
my this the same bioinformatics graduate
student was also very artistic
you know she likes drawing and she made
this beautiful model by hand drawing
actually
so this is basically just a depicts what
i just told you that the
the the oxygen response the continuous
oxygen response
between the interpro model region and
the base of the primordial
is the key to trigger this synchronize
the growth
and formation of the chlorotube now if
this
model is correct or though you would
imagine if you treat
the young the very early young florabot
with you know
oxford polar transport inhibitors for
example mpa
you should have disrupted the throttle
tube right and that's what exact that's
what we did
and and indeed you know you you know a
lot of the flowers coming out after the
treatment
you know the tube is a split so this
does highlight
sort of the the important rule of action
of oxygen response or oxygen signaling
in the formation of the protube
okay so and then and then later on you
know a few years later we'll actually
started
identify genes of those other mutants
and actually most of them have something
to do have one way or another have
something to do with
you know auxin biosynthesis or you know
transport or signaling
so it does seem to for the support that
uh oxygen signaling plays a video
central role in this
um uh um pedo fusion process
and from you know evolutionary
perspective of course
ultimately i was i i would be it was one
of my dream of course
is that you actually once we learned
that you love about the basic
genetically and developmental control
over the chronic tube formation in
memories and then
can we use that knowledge how we use
that knowledge
to actually make a tubulin or abdominis
that's one of the dreams i mean maybe in
10 years um if we can actually make
a laptop as a tubular flower that would
be
i mean don't ask me what's the use of it
it has no use it's just going to be cool
um okay so this is really the book of
the uh story i want to tell
and then in the rest of time i'm just
gonna briefly mention uh a few
let me see the timing um good timing so
just for information a few other
projects we have been working on
to sort of just uh demonstrate like how
versatile this model system this
monkey flower model system uh can be
used for um
and again like i said um whenever i
start thinking about you know either a
new project or we're thinking about what
we're gonna do
i always come back to this uh you know
diversity side of my of my flowers
um they are not a treat not a trade like
it's very common
among plants but the basic again the
basic genetic and development control
was very little known
is this yellow pigmentation the yellow
pigmentation is caused
by carotenoids right so and as you can
tell that most of the flowers they have
the ability to produce quantities look
at this pattern right but they only
produce that
in a very spacious and very precise to
control the spatial pattern
right so what likelihood is that and you
got to be the transcription factor and
things like that
so what is the bio the biosynthetic
pathway of carotenoids this whole
class of pigment had been very well
started the implants
but what actually regulate the
expression of those bioethanic genes
in the flower it was literally nothing
was known
until we started our work i mean it was
you know some of course some some of
them were already known in fluids or
other things
um but it was nothing was known really
in flower so
uh another project you know that's
really my first phd student she just
graduated this year
and her dissertation is about that so
we'll have those mutants like
the uh crocodiles noise was reduced so
that's why they could reduce the
carotenoid pigmentation
and then there's also mutants that the
the yellow was expanded
so she had been categorizing the
militants and discovered a couple of
interesting genes that that regulates
their chronic
physical pathway and then there's a
third feature a third trait that i have
been interested in for a long time
it's those are spots there's plenty of
spots i mean a lot of
flowers produce that you know you you
you keep wondering like okay so how how
does the flower know
how does the flower i'm going to produce
a pigment
in just this one cell but i'm not going
to produce that in the surrounding cells
right
and this process can happen over and
over again across the whole pattern
so how do they know that right so this
problem is really the same as like you
know
it's it's at least it's a century old
problem right isn't it how the laptop
produced that spots and how zebra
produces stripes or how giraffes produce
their patches right
and the same with the slaves and you
know
faces et cetera et cetera and uh
so so so my the same poster i should
work on a tube project so
the pilot spot project was beautifully
is a main project now
the reason i actually came to my lab you
know from you know transit from fish
behavior ecology
to plant development and evolution is
because
actually when you when you look at the
fish behavior the pigmentation
patterns of the face you actually just
saw a few images right the pigmentation
patterns of
the fish often is a very important
determinant for
meeting behavior for meeting preference
in fish so that's
why that's you know how he actually got
interested in that
but of course he realized that you know
to really study the developmental
genetic control over the path
information in fish
is going to be very challenging so
that's why he decided to
transit to a plant system that have
similar features
but now nevertheless much easier to work
with and this worker was also you know
great cobbler
uh collaboration with ben blackham i
believe here he was actually here to
give a seminar last year
so for for that reason i'm not going to
talk about this project
this just sort of shows the diversity of
the problems that we can use this
system to study so this these are all
good but so far
what are the three projects that i have
talked about that wore on
me middle should we say not pink flower
species if you have logistics um
but there was a big problem with that
species and i did not know that before i
moved to connecticut
so that species actually is an alpine
species
it's not a tolerant to heat so the sun
on the summer creating in in
the northeast basically the plants die
so which means that every year you know
i have to toss everything
by the end of well mid-june or something
like that
and i have to replant the sales in early
september and of course
we work on flowers so we won't have
flowers until
november so basically like half of the
year i don't have any materials to work
on
um and that was always one of my uh
excuse i told my department with the
dean like why we're not so productive
because you know we we don't have
materials to work out right
so this is that we said as you can tell
this the heat really just
just killed it right although this is a
this is a closer to the species so one
of the four species i mentioned earlier
that is perfectly happy in the summer
and the iphone is also happy
so the first for the first three years
i've been writing this
internal proposal you know to the uh the
vice president with
the research office i was asking them
basically to help me install a few air
conditioner units in the greenhouse
because those air conditioning units are
actually pretty expensive
and you can't even really write that
into your grand proposal because they
you know the funding agencies assume you
want to have this infrastructure in
place right
so this is really something that you
have to ask for your school
but after like three years what they've
been telling me telling me is this
now clearly this guy needs those those
infrastructure to do to do his research
but since he's the only person who is
going to benefit us
who's going to use it out let's just
screw him so
this is this is really like the the you
know the same attitude i got for the
first or three years
and then realized you know if they're
not going to help me
we're going to have to do something to
save ourselves we can't we can't just
you know like
six months of the year don't have
materials to work out right
and i you know went back to the ecology
you know we knew that this pink flower
species is our main model
as alpine species and it grows on higher
elevation
and it's not paramount to heat however
one of those other three species they
are tylenol okay they you know they are
low elevation species
and they are perfectly fine in the
summer now what if
what if i can integrate
the gene that enables this species
to parallel into this genetic background
you know if i just integrate a single
gene was very small chromosome chunk
and so we can make a basically heat
tolerant luisa
and that would solve my problem right so
we started doing that this is basically
how you make the
so-called new isogenic line or
introgression line in tomato statistical
integration is right you're basically
doing like a recurrent background into
one of the species
and you want to introduce this heat
tolerant locus
from that creative species into the
long-term background
so to make this species preparation
and in the beginning without really we
didn't really have a lot of hope for
because we didn't even know how many
genes control our treat right i mean
what if this trait requires like 10
genes
there's no way you can do this right but
fortunately
you know we just gave a short try it
looks like it's actually a single gene
it's a single
locus i can choose that and you want
about by cross population you can tell
that the cyborg is beautiful one to one
so this is like a beforehand treatment
african treatment half of them like half
of them grow happily
so the funny thing is uh about a two
years ago
our vice president for research jeff
seaman
um the guy who wanted to turn my
proposal down for three
for three years and he stepped down as
the you know vpr
and it turns out he was actually a plant
um nico physiologist or physiologist or
whatever you call that
and he actually did his dissertation
work and a large part of his career
before
before he moved on to administration not
in a diced valley in california
that he was studying thermo-tolerance he
was studying thermo-tolerance of hands
so one day he walked into my office he
was like oh i heard you guys are working
on this
a summertime project and you know
i got a i got a pair of hands now and i
don't have to do any administrative work
anymore um do you guys need an extra
pair of hands i can you know
sort of help you guys with and i look at
him i was like no we don't need an
actual hand
what we do need is air conditioning in
the greenhouse which you didn't give us
and hey girls well yeah i know i know
but it's too late for me to do that
uh was that when i stepped it down this
your university giving me a little bit
of money to uh for me to sort of
initiate whatever i wanted you
so what i can what i can do is to get
you a bunch of growth chambers how about
that
so you know he got us a few growth
chambers and
i know this probably looks like laughing
compared with what you have in cornell
um but you know we didn't even have
notes in the beginning like we didn't
have anything right so
and now you know with four growth
chambers we can actually do something
about the real molecular basis of the
physiological response
um because you need actually a real
growth chamber to do those kind of uh
fine scale temperature control um so now
i actually uh
take that as a real research direction
so the other um the other solution to
that problem
um it's you know if i was
thinking about you flat your flat your
flat uh integration doesn't work
okay then the other strategy is that we
knew that the other three species
they were carnal hate right so if i can
do multigenesis and transformation
to one of those other species i can also
use just to use it
i just switch from that species to a
thermocarbon species right
so we try we tried this species because
this one grows very
very fast and and it's a very it's easy
to grow in the greenhouse but there's a
lot of cells and actually
um even also very easy to mutate so i
had an undergrad to try to build it
mutagens they might
produce a lot of really interesting
mutants and in fact the frequency of
metagenesis
uh success it's actually much higher
than that pink flower species
and also it turns out it's very easy to
transform so when you put a flower
collar gene
on eye construction you produce a
beautiful series of
a color spectrum um and then where we
were doing the mitogenesis
and we found a bunch of mutants now they
change this uh
a striped pattern on the leaf so this is
the wild type you have this
lateral stripe pigmentation strap and a
lot of those mutants actually don't have
the striper anymore will produce a
a central spot and some of the mutants
actually produce much more expanded
strength
so like oh that's actually kind of
interesting because this lateral stripe
is a
it's a it's a sort of a larval phenotype
in the whole genus
no other species produce that and only
this one species produce it
so or like thinking about you know
evolutionary way
then what triggers the evolution of this
lava phenotype right
so then we start actually doing a
project on online line to take it out as
a real project to work on
the the origin of phenotypic laboratory
and then uh finally this is the last
thing i'm going to briefly mention
um i want to come back to the to the
diversity problem
right so we're more interested in that
how species change from one type to
another right
and in this particular case how do they
change it from like one pollination
syndrome
to another pollination syndrome or if
you look at those species right so the
lighter flower species the humidity
species are always
right red color and they have a lot of
statement pieced here are much
exerted out of the crawler so that the
hummingbird head is going to touch the
pollen directly right
on the other hand the b flowers they
often have a landing platform for the
bee
to cry into the tube and then the
statement and pistol was
hidden in the chlorotube and then this
is a softened species sort of like a
lovelapsis
it's small it's you know the color is
inconspicuous
and then the the stem and the piste are
very very close to each other so they
can solve for lights
so if you think about all the features
right it's really a whole suite of
floral treats that enable a flower
to use a particular pollinator so that's
why it's called a pollination syndrome
right but how do these different floral
treats
you know the stamen line the piston
length you know corolla tube and the
part of color they
like the volume a lot a large number of
photo traits how did the work
got assembled in the first place to
enable them to be adapted to a
particular pollinated
pollinator type and that question really
requires like you know
chromosome scale genome assembly but
then you can ask once you if you can
dissect the genetic basis of each of
the follow traits right and you can tell
okay are they all on the same chromosome
are there different chromosomes are
those um different genes in the same
region of chromosome you know inversion
so they can they can't recombine so
that's how you assemble those
differently
uh used together to produce one
particular syndrome et cetera et cetera
so we didn't really work on that problem
until you know a year or two ago
because that kind of problem requires
you know chromosome skill genome
assembly before you have that it's
really no point to do it
so now we finally have that and we
started working on it about a year or
two ago
um well i actually started um one of my
graduate students um
sort of took his dissertation project
and we started making a bunch of genes
already
um and then you can actually make those
really beautiful duogenic lines for
example
this is between the hummingbird species
and the sulfur and you can tell that you
can by
by integrating each of those gene you
know affecting just one particular treat
you can make a flower looks
basically the same as that sulfur except
the color
pigmentation is a little darker right on
the other hand you know this one looks
exactly like that
everything except the flower size is a
little bigger and those are all caused
by just the integration of a single
chunk a little chunk of dna from the
hummingbird part of the species
so we're in the process of making a
counterintuitive circle of dioxogenic
lines i'm trying to dissect
you know how those different genes got
those different ideas kind of assembled
to enable
uh you know the evolution of pollination
syndrome with that i want to end by um
coming back to the title that you know i
said the feeling for the organism
and the reason i use that title is
because actually this is the title for
the biography of robert mclean talk and
uh just to just to sort of let you know
that
i did not make this title specifically
for this talk about the bible my ninth
actually you know started her whole
career from cornell um but i've been
actually uh using this title since you
know three years ago because i was
actually quite inspired by
by this auto about my autobiography of
about nintendo that's why i actually
even took a detour to uh
to study transposable elements with the
survivor um before
it's really well because i was inspired
by um by better work
and this one quote i particularly like
and that's also sort of coming back to
the
the thesis of my talk is you know i
really did not have a pen i did not have
any sort of real vision
you know the whole everything we did is
really based on what the plan material
told us to do you know if there's a
mutant cause the chronological tube
development you know you go to study
like regular study
quality formation you know and then one
of the other projects i mentioned
um later on is is what you know either
productivities or just you know you have
to see those
plan materials and you just said okay
let's work on it so with that
um i i i want to thank you you know uh
they did you know i have a relatively
small group but they're very motivated
and
and and they did a bunch of i think a
really good work and
the funding agencies also have been very
generous too
to us to start it all the things really
have no practical values
thank you thank you for a really
excellent seminar i see virtual
clapping coming in if people want to put
questions in the chat i'll read them
but we can start off with one that i
have which is
um in the corolla tube have you looked
at the organ boundary genes and
whether they're affected yeah that's a
that's a that's a great question
and we did we did of course that's the
obvious thing to look right because
yes oxygen signaling is important but of
course the the intuitive way to think
about
how does the oxygen oxygen signaling
actually works is
maybe oxygen signaling in that boundary
in an inter-promotional region
it's by by it works by replacing the
working boundary genes right
and um but that's actually well we we
only look at the lycogens the [ __ ] the
cochlear and cocktails those orthodox
and we actually the best way to look at
that of course is to do archetypical
expression right
so you know in the wild type you are
assuming that
those genes are not explicitly in the in
the into promoted region that's why it
actually grows right
right um but if you actually express
that then you should actually disrupt
the tube
and we did that and it did not really
disrupt the tube information at all
so so now we actually don't really we
don't really think
the networking boundary genes you know
we don't think they are really like
important but it's hard to know because
we
so far we only test one type the copper
genes
but i definitely really was the issue
that uh we really
do uh absolutely true we have no idea
what's really downstream
of like oxygen signaling and i was
hoping that some of those other mutants
is going to tell us
um but most of those mutants actually
are more on upstream or the oxygen
signaling itself
um the downstream genes we haven't
really we haven't really seen any
of this candidate yet um so yeah
and it could be directly to growth which
would be pretty cool
yeah sure yeah we have a comment from
chelsea saying thank you so much a
spectacular
talk thanks for sharing so much of your
process with us
okay yeah so michael was uh commenting
about the oxygen response in the
um be the tip of the title um
that's yeah no that i mean we didn't
really talk about that in the in the
paper but yes those are
there's actually a lot of more
differences not only the the interpreter
model region
even the whole piece here um the signal
was much much weaker
um and we haven't really
[Music]
yeah it might be some models say that
the mid vein the mid
region at auction is really what's
directing the rest of the uh
lateral organ to develop yeah yeah
yeah so so again definitely the the the
the
the individual patterns are much lighter
than the wild type but again like you
know
we haven't really dig into that actually
uh uh well i i guess what i'm afraid of
is that you know if you dig into that
you figure out oh this is actually
exactly the same as you know
or adopts as leaf right and then it's
not really
you know people it's not going to think
that's very interesting because you're
just rediscovering what's already
known in your lapses um whereas the
color tube is more obvious because
that's a different that's a clear
difference between
absence and the mirrors
so elise asking she says excellent talk
could you elaborate a little
about your discovery of how floral color
patterns are controlled
right you discover how um wow
that's actually a a i i assume
she's asking about the uh dispersed
spots
um i think it's the yellow color the
yellow color
i guess um okay so the yellow color
would be yeah well yeah the yellow card
actually is
restricted to only the like the guide
that's actually the yellow card observes
that's the leica guide for the bumble
bee to sort of tell the bomb and be oh
this is what this is right
so it's actually restricted to the two
stripes
like in the in the ventral pattern and
that's actually a really really good
question we don't really know the answer
we really
yeah so one of the transcription factors
are actually activating
the uh the quaternary biosynthesis in
the flower is actually only expressed
in that like a guide but we don't know
how we don't know how is this expression
pattern
uh established and and and this is
definitely yeah it's definitely a good
question
and again the other mutant that with the
yellow get expanded
so now i'm hoping no one's gonna tell us
how was the pattern was uh restricted to
like the guide but i want it turns out
it's one of those
uh again a small on a biogen biogenesis
enzyme
and we sequence the small army pool
nevertheless so many smiles have been
changed and it's very hard to know which
one matters
so so what's in the process trying to
sort out okay which small on is actually
the important one
um so without knowing that
it's it's unclear how that pattern was
actually established
thanks um vijay is asking did you rescue
the mutant phenotype by applying the
auxin
at the inner inner inter-petal region
and from
the developmental stage do you think the
oxen comes into play
yeah that's it that's it that's a very
good question uh we did try we didn't
really try the precise localized
application just because
those flowers are um you know if you
if you don't hand them well we actually
basically haven't really figured out a
way
how to inject to localize the ox you
know inhibitory oxygen application in a
very very young photobots without
killing them without killing them
so what we did do is just do this sort
of very raw
infiltration you're using vacuum chamber
to you know soak the oxygen in but of
course
that's not really a precise look like
localized application
and it's a very blah blah you know sort
of a rudimentary application
and we just tried it on the mutant and
out of like about 500 flowers
when we got by the way actually 200
flowers we got
five of them actually the tube was um
rescued
um but in the in the market treatment
although again it's five hours
out of 200 it isn't you know it doesn't
seem very impressive
um but none of the mark treatment work
and now we've we've been planting that
thing for for years and
i haven't must have seen like thousands
of those individual flowers
none of them have ever formed the tube
you know
um but this is so five out of 200 uh uh
you know i think it's actually it means
something it means something but again
because this is not a precise localized
application so we're not expecting that
this is going to restore a lot of those
flowers because again
you don't even know where the oxen was
going into the flowers
but that's a really good question yeah i
also have one more question
um i think in your aim of making
arabidopsis into
flowering with a coral flower
i think it's this experiment gives you
like something
insights into uh maybe some localized uh
oxygen
synthesis in somewhere in the pattern in
between the petal regions that might
produce the uh
yeah yeah so i i that that's a really
good question and uh
we thought about that we thought about
using that one of those bacteria genes
right they can actually uh just like one
gene can
uh can make oxygens you don't have to do
a lot of you know
three or four genes again all right i
forgot the name of legend but yeah we
thought about actually doing that but i
figured you can't really use a
uh real constitutive promoter to do that
because then you're going to myself with
the development of a lot of other places
right so we need to have a promoter
that can drive that gene expression in
the you know you know in a spatial
pattern
that that you know matters for the
triple formation right so well you know
again
numerous is unlikely abductions now you
already have a lot of baseline
information about which promoter
might be you know active in which region
and for us
a lot of the things we have to start
from scratch so where we are
that's a great idea and we're still
trying to figure out what kind of
promoter might work
um and and that would be definitely the
first thing to try but what you know
even though
we might be able to find a promoter like
that and then to do that it makes the
deal necessarily produce
the pattern just because this also may
have something to do with oxygen
transport
not only the biosynthesis right um but i
think the bible thinks it is a place to
start with i told you that great
yeah any more questions i have i have a
question
uh fantastic talk um i'm wondering if
you saw
any phenotypes in the sepals i guess i'm
thinking of
in in the astrids that you you get the
evolution of a fused corolla but as well
as a fuse
calyx um or perhaps i mean if you didn't
see any phenotypes
those may have been independent events
that just so happened to that's a that's
a really good question that's a really
good question and we did we did actually
given the freight mutants
the cadets was not let's just split it's
the cooler tube but they do show some
sort of
uh uh you know uh a split or
defective list of the of the formation
of the tube the reason we didn't really
focus on that just because um
the two the chlorotube the chlorotube
and the kids cube is
you know they are definitely
developmentally controlled separately
right
because even on abdomens you have
mutants that
have you know the the kid is kind of
like a father from a tube right
but even as i as father i am aware of
there was no abdomen with the crueler
formula tube right so they are
definitely different
and of course you know the way this is
you know i don't want to be too
practical but it's really
you know when you run a research program
this is really something you do want to
consider right if you work on the kid x
why don't you just use the laptops why
don't you just use you know the laptops
and built-in which has a tube already
right and just look at what happened
there right
and and if you you know again like
working on any other systems it's much
harder than what adapts it's just
because you know what that's
you know if you want to have a report
line you can ask people to give you
right
um you know or milton you can just ask
you know to the waterline
in a data bank but for any other systems
i'm sure for you know the same for corn
and for you know for for the
organism you guys are working on you
have to make everything yourself
and everything you know make anything it
takes so much time so
you have to you know sort of focus on
the things that can most
distinguish your system to to
to other dances really yeah that makes
sense
thank you yeah anyone else
those are definitely really good
questions i i really enjoy
those questions thank you for a
fantastic talk
really enjoyed it thank you guys so much
bye
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu